and is it true that you are mistaken for
daniel radcliffe
it happens a lot and he's mistaken for
me and apparently
signs my name because
cheeky yeah it saves you the time you're
busy
it is i was in an elevator once this was
many years ago but i was in an elevator
and you know that thing when you're in
an elevator with one other person and
there's that kind of awkward silence
and you're both kind of looking busy
doing not like at the buttons
you know and so there was that and i
could tell that this by this guy's
energy that he wanted to say something
he was working it up working it up
working it up
and then all of a sudden he burst out
and said harry potter
[Laughter]
and i was like no
so funny well let's see how it could
happen let's have a look at some
examples
there you are now turn full face
smile
it's not do you mean i do sort of see it
let's
try another one let's try another one
okay turn to the side
that's not so good uh let's see one more
you're both in your own ways sort of sex
symbols
there are well you are don't laugh at
that
encourage the guests
your sex symbols
yes ladies and gentlemen
it is true you you get the attention of
the ladies
yes you get you get i don't get but they
don't want to shag me though they want
to
they write to me and say oh you seem
nice would you like to come to the
guildford golden
area for a pint that's quite a lot right
there
isn't it of oddness it's it's quite
enough when i did
i did a play here a long time ago
almost 20 years ago in 1990 called
burnedness
and i kept i had i don't
anymore but i had a whole collection
of the letters i received
many of which had accompanying photos
and many of the photos were
sort of along the order of
either this uh is me
on my beach vacation
last year in croatia on the dalmatian
coast
it happened to be a nude beach
see this is what i don't get okay this
is me with my puppy
i'll just crack one off now then
so if it wasn't that sort of photograph
what sort of photograph would it be
a full close-up of it
what pudenda or the puppy
the the croatian coastline
croatian girls
put that in an envelope for mr mcmahon
[Music]
better this time
that's it that's beautiful darling
that's beautiful
[Music]
[Laughter]
i wasn't in one of those at the station
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know you just what do you say
back to them
in a way you say thank you
it's lovely that's very very kind it's
fascinating
but i'm more
[Applause]
you're either a potter or a leaver
you're either someone if you're asked
where your keys are you'll say they're
where i put them in which case you're a
good human
or you'll say that where i left them in
which case you will die of dysentery
and in relationships you always get one
with the other you always get a putter
with a lever because two putters will
kill each other
and it justify you know because i've
always been the putter so i've always
been the one going oh that goes there
and that's please love me
because it is interesting this thing
about like quirky rules
for living because we we've we've tried
it with audience form because we thought
oh this will be funny
and so when when do people laugh at you
for your rules or they're going to go
yes you're so right we do need rules for
living yeah no it's a bit of but i i
i make sure that everyone i talk about
people will
at least see the logic behind i don't
want to be the knotter on stage just
going i can only eat blue ones
so i i like to feel people not and
everyone had you're out of compliment
everyone has something even if you don't
know if you
you'll be at someone's house on the
toilet and you will turn their toilet
roll around
without even knowing you've done it and
everyone's got a little yeah you see
you're all probably need something
did you have a quirky habit do you have
a rule do you have a quirky habit like a
habit like uh
yeah i used to have some crazy
pre-performance
like quirks that i i've decided to get
rid of all of those because i'm the
personality type that if i
uh if i decide that i'm going to start
needing things before i go on stage
it's just going to escalate to the point
of being completely intolerable
but in the first two or three years of
my career i
um i decided in my own crazy mind that i
couldn't
go on stage unless i had some kind of um
like patterned or colored
socks and underwear uh i know crazy but
i could not have white
underwear socks i just thought if i if i
go out on stage in white socks and
underwear
it's going to be the worst show i've
ever had in my life so i would actively
find like polka dot
underwear on stage yeah because already
i'm thinking you're right white socks
are wrong
that's right white underpants is that
good but white socks also white
underwear in a situation of high stress
is awesome
maybe that's subconsciously that's what
i was thinking
yeah catherine what do you yeah no the
thing i still do but i think it's
related to superstition you know that
thing they say you should never cross on
the stairs
well i do cross people on the stairs but
i always say in my mind when when i
cross someone on the stairs or they
cross me on the stairs
i wish you luck and no no what is it oh
[__] oh god
no here it is when someone cross me on
the stairs i go you'll bring me luck
i'll bring you look and that's what i
say
in my head i'm a witch
i do and i can't not say it i can't not
say it in my head
david you crazy
do you know something something that i'm
aware i
i i've conquered one i used to spend an
awful lot of time
if you blokes tend to have lots of black
socks right
and i had to get the right black sock
with the right black salt and i would
spend hours
with socks
but look graham look look this has
changed my life oh no no no this has
changed my life
i can't i'm so excited i can't get my
look this will change my life with a
hidden
pattern
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can tell and secretly secreted in
your shoe
is the answer to all your ones and these
ones even better because these ones
tell you what day to wear them on
[Applause]
you've changed my life
but your school was quite rough yes my
school was i grew up in
pretty much like ghetto i know it's the
blonde hair blue eyes that
that tricks you but then you hear me
talk and then you go what is like what's
wrong with this person
would you get into proper fights yeah
well you had to being a skinny white
girl
i mean that's that's a you have to be
able to defend yourself
yeah yeah do you have a hood name
[Applause]
[Laughter]
do you want to show them what you're
packing today no i tucked it
okay oh you mean this yeah
[Applause]
yeah i do she says she's packing yeah we
meant lip gloss now
we were talking about uh you're going to
school because
your parents but your parents weren't
very strict and your granny
your granny was like a bear grylls my
granny would have put you to shame
tell me about your grandma okay my
granny was like she lived off the land i
mean literally
she raised everything that she that she
ate
and um and made all her own clothes and
everything and during the summer she
would go to arizona
because she where she lived in the
valley in california that was
is about 100 degrees in the summer but
it was too cold for her so she had to go
to arizona where it's 120 degrees during
the summer
and she would walk around with just like
her skirt on
and a pair of sandals topless and now
this is a woman who has six children
okay they were like they were down here
yeah they were
they were they were the bad teacher
would not have worn them no uh they were
like kind of below the waistband
probably where they belong where god
intended
where you could just like flip them over
the shoulder for the baby
that's what they do in africa right they
do they
that's why boobies are supposed to sag
so that you can put them over the
shoulder wrap it under
so the babies on the back can eat suckle
and you don't have to stop working
yeah a little lesson right there you go
so this is going to help if your granny
did that so my i don't know if she ever
actually did it
it's good but she would go hunting in
the desert with a machete and she would
come back
with a rattlesnakes and my my uncle said
that his
one of his his visuals of his mother is
like walking
up with sandals skirt topless beheaded
snake
and bloody machete and a smile and a
smile got dinner
you could have loved the bear yeah
absolutely is that amazing yeah
because you're now you're growing you
had snake i have had snake
yeah it tastes like chicken it doesn't
taste like chicken
they always say everything tastes like
chicken but it doesn't survival food
doesn't taste like chicken it's
no i had i had um chicken one time that
tastes like cat
i was pretty sure that it was bad
it tastes like cat it smells like that
yeah i was like i took the leg and i was
like that's not a chicken leg
that's funny that's the biggest chicken
leg up yeah
this chicken had a fall yeah yeah
stars in lovely gowns all dressed up
that's your that's where you
that's your home yeah because now the
oscars were you doing the red carpet
i did the red carpet this year and uh it
was you weren't there
no no working busy busy yes
hi who you wearing or who the [__] are
you
what's this f-word business this is
called anybody can say this guy you can
oh you can say that in english
television
i love that yeah i just say it a bunch
of times yeah you go for it
no oh it feels wrong to me
really what can't you say here
that's cool so don't say it okay
the thing is i see you in the red carpet
and you seem fearless
but i looked at your website and there
you actually go into
the things you'd like to ask people but
you don't have the nerve
well you you there are certain rules
that you just don't ask people
certain things to their face okay
so some of the stars you have uh
brittany uh
what what would you like to ask brittany
well i would have loved to say
why not the eyebrows also going for a
[__] do it
and then of course katie and tom now
what
my favorites what would you say it looks
like you popped out of a can i shouldn't
say
this is a bad show for me to be honest
katie what would you say to katie you
know the whole thing about the baby he's
there
for the the birth and i said was he
there for the conception
it was fun no i remember when
she was pregnant the new york posted a
big headline saying mission impossible
and finally uh penelope cruz what would
you what would you be asking for
you love her every all the men loved
don't they
it's kind of a mesh outfit too it looks
like it kind of just goes into one i'm
just looking for the nipples
[Music]
looking for the nipples now um
you want to see my nipples look at my
toes
[Applause]
i'd actually love to see your nipples i
know you would
she's so beautiful but i would love to
say to her do you understand yourself
i don't know what she's talking about
but she's kind of cute oh she's go she
was the prettiest at the
at the oscars you think she was the
prettiest oh there was no question about
it who was the worst dress
uh oh two uh nicole kidman
in that long red dress with that white
face she looked like a ketchup bottle
which ended up i guess that's the
question
she and i are oh and i love herself
meryl streep oh winona ryder would not
have stolen that dress
it was just
she looks like a a chinese lesbian
why why was she wearing that outfit yes
you get to the point where you go why
not
i mean how many times has she been i
guess if you know you're not going to
win you knew helen and it's the 30th
time there and you're kind of feeling a
little different
and you know yeah like on a necklace it
looks quite heavy though
it looks like one of those pensioner
alarm things doesn't it you know
meryl knows help is on its way
full halfway down the red carpet yes it
looks heavy doesn't it
i can't get it
[Music]
you